you back to that breaking news coming
from New York the Attorney General suing
former president Donald Trump and his
three adult children let's listen into a
news conference
upon by Banks and insurers
Mr Trump and Mr weisselberg would meet
to review and approve the final
statement every year
Mr Trump made known through Alan
weisselberg that he wanted his net worth
reflected on the statements to increase
a desire Mr weiselberg and others
carried out year after year
in their fraudulent preparation of the
statements
and when asked
about these meetings under oath as part
of our deposition
both men
Mr Trump
and Mr weisselberg invoked their Fifth
Amendment privilege against
self-incrimination
and they refused to answer
when asked under oath
if he
Mr Trump continued to review and approve
the statements after becoming president
of the United States in 2017
. Mr Trump again
invoked his Fifth Amendment privilege
and refused to answer
over the course of our investigation
we found that Mr Trump
his children
the Trump organization created and used
more than 200 false and misleading asset
valuations on his statement of financial
condition over that 10-year period
they issue statements that were in clear
violation of General accepted principles
in the general accounting principles in
the United States despite representing
that these statements were prepared in
accordance
with these principles
some of the common tactics they used
include
representing that Mr Trump had cash on
hand that he did not have
ignoring critical restrictions that
would significantly impact property
values when setting valuations
changing the methodology used to Value
properties from year to year without
reason or notice and using vastly
different methods to Value different
properties even in the same year
and including tangible items
such as brand premiums the Trump premium
when calculating an asset's value
despite the fact that they ignored the
advice of outside professionals they
also ignored the advice and an
appraisals of outside professionals
despite claiming those individuals
provided certain figures
for example
they received a series of Bank ordered
appraisals for the commercial property
at 40 Wall Street
in New York City that calculated the
value of the property at 200 million
dollars as of August 2010.
and 220 million dollars as of November
2012.
yet
in his 2011
statement Mr Trump listed 40 Wall Street
with a value of 524 million dollars
which increased to 530 million dollars
over the next two years
more than twice the value calculated by
the professionals
even more egregious
the 500 and Million Dollar Plus
valuation was attributed
to information from the appraiser who
valued the building at just over
200 million dollars
another deceptive strategy they employed
was to use objectively false numbers to
calculate property values
take Mr Trump's Triplex
you know the triplex apartment in Trump
Tower on Fifth Avenue
Mr Trump represented that his apartment
spanned more than 30 000 square feet
which was the basis for valuing the
apartment
in reality
the apartment had an area of less than
11
000 square feet
something that Mr Trump was well aware
of
and based on that inflated square
footage the value of the apartment in
2015 and 2016 was 327 million dollars
to this date
no apartment in New York City has ever
sold for close to that amount
tripling the size of the apartment for
purposes of the valuation was
intentional and deliberate fraud
not an honest mistake
Mr Trump was intimately familiar with
the layout of both the building
and the apartment having personally
overseen the construction
of both
despite his foreign testimony before
invoking his Fifth Amendment privilege
Mr weisselberg conceded
that using the false square footage
improperly inflated the value of the
apartment almost
threefold
Mr weisselberg admitted that this
amounted to a overstatement of give or
take 200 million dollars
misrepresenting the size of the
apartment was only one of the many ways
that Mr Trump intentionally misvalued
his asset for the purposes of increasing
his net worth
and inducing Banks to offer more
favorable terms
Mr Trump also routinely ignored legal
restrictions on development rights
and marketability
on properties that would significantly
decrease property values
for example
let's take Trump Park Avenue in New York
this building contains both commercial
and residential space
the unsold residential condo units owned
by Mr Trump and the Trump organization
represented the Lions share of the
reported value for this property
Mr Trump and his children
intentionally ignored legal restrictions
on some of the units that would have had
that would have drastically changed the
valuation specifically
the 12 12 of those units were actually
rent stabilized Apartments
a professional appraiser valued those 12
units at around seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
noting that the rent stabilized units
cannot be marketed as individual units
for sale because the current tenants
cannot be forced to leave
despite this professional valuation and
Mr Trump knowing full well the legal
restrictions the 12 rent stabilized
units were valued he valued them
collectively on his statements at 49
million dollars
that is about 65 times
the appraised valuation
Mr Trump also blatantly ignored legal
restrictions at Mar-A-Lago
Mar-A-Lago was valued on the false
premise that it sat on unrestricted
property and could be developed for
residential use
however
Mr Trump knew that Mar-A-Lago was
subject to a host of onerous
restrictions and limitations
Mr Trump himself signed Deeds sharply
restricting changes to the property and
donating his residential development
rights in an effort to get a tax
deduction and later to lower his
property
taxes on the property
the Deeds also require Mr Trump to
donate over 23 percent of mar-a-lago's
value to the historic trust for historic
preservation if he ever sold it
that is the New York attorney general
giving a press conference there in New
York regarding the suing of former
president Donald Trump and his three
adult children alleging business fraud